まあ大変忙しい時期になりまして
まあ皆様には呼吸する暇もないほど忙しいと思いますけど
まあそれでも今日ご足労いただきまして
本当に大変よろしい楽しいことで感謝いたします
どうもありがとうございます
で まあ何かお釈迦様の言葉で人生に役に立つことがあるならば
それはまあお聖坊としていただければいいんじゃないかなと
で ブッダの世界で まあ仏教の世界では
やっぱり何よりも幸福というのは
この真理を知ることであります
ですから まあ真理をまあなんとか勉強しようとすることは
我々にとっては 生きているものにとっては大変ありがたいことなんです
まあ幸福はいろいろあると思いますけどね
それは我々考えている幸福で
で どちらにしたっても
正しいものを知っているならば
物事について 自分について正しい法則を知っているならば
まあ自分に自由自在に
希望通りに あの物事を変化させたり
あるいは変化させなかったりとかね
まあいろいろように人生の管理できるんですよ
えーだから幸福っていうのはそうやって自制できることなんですよ
自己管理 自己コントロールできること
それが幸福なんですよ
勉強したいと思うならば
そのように自己管理をする
何か他の希望願望あるならば
まあそれは実現できるようにと自己管理を自己コントロールをする
それができないんだから
みんな問題にしているんですね
豊かになりたいんだけど
どうもなかなかそうはなれませんと
じゃあどうすればいいかと
勉強はしたいんだけど
どうもなかなか頭が動いてくれませんと
どうすればいいかと  そのような質問が出てくると
勉強の仕方とか まあ学問が出てきて
商売繁盛する方法とか学問が出てきて
で マネージメントといえば
もう英語だったらもうかなりの分野なんですね
大学に入ってみると もうマネージメントという学科まであるんですよ
ビジネスマネージメントといって
日本語で何言うかわかりませんですけど
で まあ経営論 経営学ですね
経営方法とかね そうやって膨大な知識
方法論 ハウツーというね
論が成り立ってますね
で それ何なのかというと
まあうまく経営したいんだけど
うまくいかないんですね
ではどうすればいいかと
で 幸福な家族をどうやって築けばよろしいかと
まあ築きたいんですよ
でもうまくいかない その場合は誰かに聞くんですね
どうすればいいかと それでまあ宗教からまあもう霊の能力者から科学者まで
哲学者まで まあいろんな人がいろんなことを言うんですよ
平和な豊かな家族を築くために孝行するべきですよとかね
で その中にもう一つ言ってあげようという
もう一つ付け加えようということは
仏教はしません この方法論というのは世の中でありすぎでしょうしね
だからそんなものはいくら勉強したっても勉強しきれません
それで全部まとめて仏教は真理を語ろうではないかと
だからわかりやすく言えば自己コントロールはできない
例えば 平和な家族を築きたいと思うならば
その思った人がその結果を結果になるように
希望通りの結果になるように
自分の生き方を管理してコントロールして自制しなくてはいけないんでしょうね
自分で何もやらないで
もう結果が得られるということは
ちょっと甘い話になりますね
で 会社のみんなまとめてうまく仕事をしてほしいと管理者が思うならば
その人はその方向へ向かって
その目的を目指して自己管理をしなくちゃいけないんですよ
いわゆる自制しなくちゃいけないんですね
それできない場合は問題起きてくるんですね
あるいは自分で何もしようとしないで
努力しようとしないで
ただ結果だけ望むと で
それはちょっと甘すぎの話になるんですね
私がこういうふうに言葉にしてみると
みんなそんなことはありっこはないんだと
バカなことを言うんじゃないよと思うかもしれません
何もしないで結果だけ望むわけじゃないんではないかと
我々はいろんなことをしているんではないかと
そんなことじゃないんですよ
結局は我々は自分では何もしないで
ただ恵みだけを欲しがるんですよ
自分でやるべき仕事を分担を果たさないで
良い結果だけ希望する
それには仏教は欲望と言うんですよ
だから欲望っていうのは愚か者
アホな人 無知な人 人生失敗する人
何一つも成功できない人を持つものなんです
そこで何か目的があるならば
その目的を実現するために自己コントロール自制をする人にとっては
それが欲望ではないんですよ
それは自分の計画があって
その計画で計算上成り立っている結果なんですね
すごい具体的なことなんです
なぜならば その具体的な結果を目指して
その人はもう着々と自己管理をしながら動いているんですよ
それはあまり欲望という言葉で言わなくてもいいんじゃないかなと
それはまあただ目的とかね
オブジェクティブとか
英語で言えば まあ何か何かの目的というぐらいのことで
マラソンにはゴールというものがありまして
自分で走ろうともしないで 1番目になりたいと記録を出したいと思うと
それが欲望で無知な人で
愚か者で何一つもやらん人なんですね
だからまあ不幸者で もういわゆる失敗者なんですよ
そういうことで 仏教はかなりこの欲望というものはね
タンナーとかね 渇愛とかね言って
それはすごい厳しく否定するんですよ
それはお釈迦様はすごい論理的にお語りになっているものだと思います
でも 世界から厳しい批判というか非難というかね
まあ受けることになるんです
欲望がなければ何もできないのではないかとかね
こんな欲なんかは捨てることはないんではないかとかね
言ってブッダの言葉に逆らうんですよ
ブッダが教える道を歩もうとはしないんですね
でもお釈迦様はそれにどんな反応するかというと
この愚か者たちがね 今も不幸で
これからも不幸になるんだと
勝手にしろと という態度をとるんですね
聞かないと出ていいけど
堂々と言うんです あなたと話す暇がないんだと
出て行きなさいと だからお釈迦様は宗教家ではなかったんです
宗教家というのはすごく優しくてね
ものすごい甘い言葉をかけてきて
みんな出ていらっしゃいとかね
みんな救ってやるぞと
苦しんでいる人も 幸福な人も
誰でも出ていらっしゃいと
私のところに安らぎがあるんだぞとかね
そうやっておだてて話すんですよ
でも聖書にも書いてます
甘い言葉を言うのは悪魔やと
ですから 聖書は完全に悪魔の言葉なんです
でも甘い言葉しかないんだから
お釈迦様は宗教家ではなくて
すごい現実的で合理的で真理を語っていくんですね
だから真理を知るということは
法則を知るということ
自分に対して 他人に対して
世界に対して 本当にどのようなあるものかと
それでそれを知っていると
いとも簡単に自己管理というものは自分をコントロールすることができるんです
それで自分をコントロールする
自己自制すると言った途端
偉い暗い顔をする場合もあります
皆様はいかが分かりませんだけど
だから心に直接話すんだから
全然質問もしないし 自分を出してくれないんだからね
それは置いておいて 私はいろいろ本やらいろんなところから読んだところから話しますけど
で これは危険だと 特に心理学の世界で言うんですね
自制やらね 抑圧は危険だとかね
だから何だかんだも感情も何でも放棄して
犬のままでわがままで気楽に生きることかと
好き勝手でとこちらが聞きたいんですけどね
だから精神的な病気になった人々は
この自分の感情 欲望 そういうものをあまりにも抑えて抑えていたんだから爆発したんだと
それ聞いたところで みんなやっぱり自己管理は良くないんだ
自己コントロール良くないんだ
自制が良くないんだと
すぐみんな世界中納得する
その通りだと だって 何とかのアホなバカな人がね
皮膚だけ白ければ 言っていることは全部正しいということになるでしょうし
で 問題はそういう学者たちが
誰をこの自分の研究題材というんですか
研究材料に使っているかということなんですよ
この心理学書いてる人々は
みんな精神的な病気な人々
頭イカってる人々を研究材料にして語っているんですよ
すごい成功している人々
億万長者になっている人々
貧しい家庭で生まれて
それでも頑張ってアメリカの大統領になった人々とかね
その人々の心の働き 生き方
それは勉強しない 研究材料にしない
生まれつきから部屋から出たくなくて出たくないとかね
お母さんがそばにいないと二十歳なのに泣き崩れるとかね
そんなふうな人々を研究材料にして
まあ私たちに教えてくれる
それも鵜呑みにしてね
よく従うことで だからそういう
まあ我々 私たちから仏教の側から見れば
もうあまりにもおかしくて
屁理屈で 何やと これはと
我々は何かモデルにするならば
自分よりちょっと上のものをモデルにするんじゃないんでしょうかと
あの人をモデルにそうと思ったら
その人は確実に自分より能力のある上の人でないと
もう何にもならんでしょうに
だから精神的な指導 精神的な自分の心を管理するためにというか
心を育てるために 何か研究材料としてね
何かもう参考文献として使うならば
精神的にイカれている人のやり方ではなくて
たくさん人を殺した人の例じゃなくて
立派な人々のことを勉強するべきなんですよ
では聞きますけど その有名になった人々
歴史に名乗っている 残っている人々はわがままで好き勝手で生きていたんですかね
エイブラハムリンカーンとか
酒におぼれて 遊びにふざけて
いい加減で その人々はもう沼津食わす状態で
遊びたくたっても遊べないで
寝たくたっても寝ないで
いろいろと苦労しながら
自分の本能から出てくる汚らわしい感情をね
管理したんだからうまくいったんじゃないですか
それで自己コントロールというと暗い顔をすると
ならば その人々の運命というのは決まってるんですよ
だから決して自制というのは
自己管理というのは 自分をコントロールするということは
これは変な話でも危険な話でもないんです
それこそ人間やるべきことなんです
明るく生きたいと 成功したいと
豊かになりたいと 平和になりたいと
と思うならば 自分を自制することしか道がないんです
だからそれで人々が 2つに分かれてきますよ
そんな話 嫌な人とそんな話を聞いて
じゃあ勇気出しましょうという人々がね
そこでそんな話は嫌やという人々は
もうそれからもどんどんどんどん滑って滑っていくんです
随分楽です ものすごい活況
ついている滑り台にもう座ってるんだから
だから楽な道 滑って不幸になると
じゃあ頑張ってみるぞという人々は
自己コントロールして自制をして
この世もあの世も幸福を自分のものにするんです
だからですよ の中で成功している人々は少ないのは
なのは ものすごい頭のいい天才的な知識人はなぜ少ないかというと
平和な人間が少ないでしょうに
お互いに喧嘩し合ったり
憎しみ合ったりする人々はものすごい多いでしょうに
だから自制する 自己コントロールする人っていうのは
もうもう一握りぐらいと
人類の中でものすごい少ない
でも我々一般的にはみんなやることやるんだぞという論理でしょ
みんなやってるんだったらやってやりますと
どういう考え方ですかね
普通に言えば みんなやってるんだったらやめなさいよと
正しく言えばろくなことじゃないんだと
みんな堂々と元気でやってるでしょ
確実に悪いことなんです
不幸になることなんです
それは統計学的にわかるでしょうに
こういう中で成功している人々っていうのは
もう 1万人に一人ぐらいでしょうし
それでたくさん人々をやるんだったら
まあやめた方がいいでしょうに
みんなやってるんだから
私はやってませんと ふうな思考でないと
うまくいかないんですよ
それでなぜ我々には自分を管理できないか
自分の感情をコントロールできないのかというと
これ法則は知らないんだからなんです
自分って何なのかとはっきりと具体的に明確に知って
その自分というものはこういうふうに動くものだと
こういうふうに反応する機能だとわかると
この反応ではなくて この反応が欲しいというならば
わかった人がもうこの管理できるんですよ
掌握できるんですよ そういうことで
この自分って何たるものかと
どのようにこれは変化していくんでしょうかと
そこら辺のプロセスね
お釈迦様は真理と言うんです
その教えに だから自分のことなんですよ
真理っていうのは 自分を知ることは真理を知ることなんです
自分イコール真理なんです
そんなに難しいことじゃないんです
自分を知る者は真理を知っています
それで自分が何か期待があるならば
何か希望があるならば
もう自分のことをちゃんと知ってるんだから
それはもう得ようとすることはいたって簡単にできます
そういうことだから この世の中で一番幸福なことは何なのかというと
真理を聞くこと 覚えておけば一番役に立つものっていうのは真理のみなんです
ですから 幸福の言葉を聞いて損しない
得のみをする言葉で言えば真理の言葉なんですね
そういうことで  今日は計算してしゃべろうと思っているんです
皆様もこのこういう真理の言葉を聞いて
聞く機会あったことも幸福に思って
まあ来年もなんとかうまくいきますようにと
まあ期待希望した方がいいんじゃないかなと思います
では テーマに入ります
で 考えること まず 考えるということはどういうことかと
そのシステムを説明いたします
考えるためには 我々にはデータというものが必要なんです
何かに過ぎて考えるんです
でも考えるということはおかしいことあれ
あの...対角ってなんとかないんですね
まあ英語で言えば I think でもう十分ですね
オブジェクトというもの入らないんですよ
入らなきゃおかしいんですよ
ですから このエモーションと同じく扱っていますよ
例えば  I am happy とかね
私が楽しいとか言っちゃう場合は
もうオブジェクトという
あれ 何て言います？日本語で
え？目的格がなくなっちゃうんですね
でも私は食べると言ったら意味がないんですよ
私が食べますと言って
何言ってるんですかと
私がといえば 何々をと入れないとね
人を入れたってもいいんです
そうすると意味のある文章になるんですよ
私が何々を食べますと言えば
意味のある文章で 私が楽しいと言っちゃうと
それに何々を入れる必要ないんですね
エモーションですよ  myself と同じくなっちゃうんですね
ですから 私があなたを見てます
見ています 正しい文章でしょ
私があなたを考えています
正しい？変ですよ 文章は
うん まあ一応 まあ私はまあ一応まあこれ日本の思考じゃないんだからね
ブッダの思考はね で 頭の中では日本語というよりも
ちょっと外国語もいろいろごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃしていますから
英語で言えば I think で十分でしょう
I think you と言ったら全然文法おかしくてね
何ということになっちゃうんです
だから I think of you, I think about you とか
なんとかこのつなぎ言葉使わないと
その場合は英語の文法で言えばインダイレクトオブジェクトと言うんですね
直接の目的語ではなくて
間接的な目的語になっちゃうんですね
ダイレクトオブジェクト
インダイレクトオブジェクト
オブジェクト 2つに 2つがありますからね
はい それで私は何言いたがってますかというと
なんか世間では考えることも一つエモーションとして扱っているんです
だから もしかすると このテキストの紹介文章にも
まあ人っていうのはね
何でしたっけ？何の足？考える
考える足であると それだったらエモーションなんですよ
だから 西洋の世界では
哲学的な世界でも 考えることは人間のエモーションの一部として
私が楽しいと 私が悲しいと
そういうふうなものと同じもので扱ってます
ではそれが正しいですかと
仏教から見ればそうじゃなくて
何かデータがあって それを考えるんですよ
だからエモーションと一緒のものじゃないんです
一つの仕事なんです では
情報なしにデータがなしに
考えられますか？何か
データが何もない 情報が何もない
その場合 何 何考えてるんですかね
思考の機能ありますかね
その場合は 何か人がもう考えているというと
何かを考えているんですよ
だから考えるというところで
もうどちらでも皆様好き勝手に認めるのはいいんですけど
あの 学問の世界で考えているような
これはエモーションみたいな一部フィーリングみたいな一部ではありません
一つのちゃんとした行為なんです
例えば私がちょっと気持ち悪いとかね
私はちょっと悲しいとかいうのはもうどうにもならんことでしょうに
まあそれの原因はあるかもしれませんよ
その原因を変えればもう悲しいことはなくなるかもしれませんだけど
悲しくなったことは受動的で
どうにもならんことなんですよ
何か何か食べ物があって
それを食べたところで美味しかったと
美味しく感じることは
その人にとってはどうにもならんことでしょうに
だからエモーションというのは受動的な機能なんですよ Subjective
function です
考えることはそうじゃないんです
で 私はね 例えば歩くということがありますね
その場合 自分で歩いているんですよ
どうにもならん状態じゃないんです
私が歩いているんだけど
何とかしてちょうだいと
そういう話 自分でやめればいいでしょうに
歩きたくなければ でもエモーションの場合は
これはちょっと無理ですね
私はもう例えばメロンを食べると
おいしくてたまらないんだと
これは何とかしてくれませんかと
俺は何もできませんですけどね
ですから まず考えることは能動的な機能であること
よく理解した方がいいんじゃないかなと思います
それは思考のファンクションの基本的なところは
仏教はちょっと脱線というかね
ちょっと変わってるんです
西洋と だからわかりやすく言えば
人間は考える葦といったのは
まああまりああそうということで
すごいことではないけど
全然びっくりしない まあどんな人にも言えるものやということで終わっちゃうんです
では データって何なのかと
だからそこのポイントを明確にしないと
思考は能動的なものであるということは知っていただけないと
このデータについては語らなくなっちゃうんです
そこで我々はもう XYB とか何とかとか
何かを考えているんです
この 何かを考える だから
このデータがどのように我々に入りますかね
それがまあ仏教の場合はもう簡単で
目から入る 耳から入ると
鼻から入ると 舌から入ると
体の皮膚からデータが入る
それからまあ仏教は六根ですからね
五感の話じゃないんだから
六感の話だからね 意識というものもあるんだと
意識にもいろいろデータが
ぶつけて思考回転するんだと
で 我々は考えるという場合は
この意識の回転 大体一般的には思ってるんですね
で 体に空気が触れると寒い寒いと感じますね
で そこまではどうにもならんことで
体に冷たい空気が触れる
寒くなる 寒いと それからそのデータを意識で受け取るんですね
受け取ってそれから考え始めるんです
例えば今日は異常に寒いとかね
なんで寒い日々が続けるだろうとかね
私は寒さに弱いとかね
もうちょっと厚い服を着て着た方が良かったんではないかとかね
出かける前にポケットにあれなんて言いますか
なんとかカイロなんか４枚ぐらい持ってきた方が良かったんではないかとかね
で 早く暖房ついてるところどこかに行きたいとか
そういうふうに思考が考えることが機能するんですね
入ったデータは冷たい空気を体に触れたということで
でも その思考パターンを見てください
全部過去のデータなんですね
例えば私が寒さに弱いというのは
本当は自分の経験じゃないんです
誰かが言うんですよ 言ったら
ああそうですかと それで決めつけます
じゃあ では私が寒さに弱いと
まあ子供の頃 誰か誰かがそう言うんですよ
言ったら じゃあその通りにしますということになるんです
で みんなものを観察しないでしょうと思いますけど
小さい時はそうやって言われる通りに自分がそんなもんやと思っちゃうんです
でも我々大人になって
みんなそういうふうにいろんなことを言うんですよ
あなたはこういう人ですよ
こういう人ですよとかね
このアホな人みたい その通りに演じようとするんです
だから自分って何ですかと
私にすればそれほど腹が立つというかね
機嫌が悪くなることがないんです
自分のことをもう随分決めつけてくれるんですね
最近のこと 私の思考まで
あなただったらこう考えるでしょうと
その人にはどなったんです
いい加減にしなさいと
人のことよくもわかるもんですねとかね
他人のこと あんた あんたのことわかってますかと
人間っていうのは 自分でも自分のことをわかってないのに
よくも私のことをよくよくわかっていることだと
ものすごく もうもうまあまあ
そこで止まりましたけどね
それ以上私は言い合っちゃうと
もう私にも自己管理できなくなるんだからね
それでめちゃくちゃなんですね
何一つもできなくなるんですね
そこそちらで勝手に考えた通りに
私は演じなくちゃいけないんだから
なんでどこかのアホの言う通りに演じなくちゃあかんですかね
真理通りに生きていればいいでしょうに
誰かがおいしいと決めたら
なんで私はそれおいしい
おいしいと言わなくちゃあかんですかね
ということになるんですよ
まあとにかく我々大人になっても
年取ってじじいになって老人になってやっても
みんな性格決めてくれるんですね
そういう世界なんですよ
人間生きてる世界っていうのは
それであの小さい時はもう大体そこに嵌めてしまって
かけられて この罠にはめられちゃって
まあそれで私は寒さに弱いとかね
で決めつけちゃう だから客観的にデータを取ろうとはしないんです
だからまあ 私 私個人が寒さに弱いか強いかってみんなに聞かないとね
それぞれみんな決めつけてくれます
本人の意思は関係ないんです
であの赤ちゃんの場合はね
残酷で 母親が自分が寒さに弱いと思ったら
ちょっと赤ちゃんには２０キロぐらい服を着せるんですよ
それで赤ちゃんってのはものすごい汗かき屋でしょうし
すごい動くでしょうし
暑くてたまらんですけど
地獄の苦しみを味わわなくちゃいけない
それで性格が悪くなるし
だから自分が寒いんだったら
もう自分で服を着ればいいのに
赤ちゃんにいっぱいいっぱいいっぱいいっぱい着させちゃうと
そこで結んで縛っておくんだからね
体 足 中の内臓 何一つ動かなくなっちゃうんですね
全部細胞は激しく活動している年で
それをストップさせて
その子供にどれほどね
苦しませて苦しみを味わさせているかというと
だからそれはもうその本人の過去の業かもしれませんだから私は関係ないということにしていますけど
そういうところに生まれたならば
そういうふうになりなさいと
生まれてきたあなたが悪いんだと
だからまあ 私は一応自分のことを客観的に見てみたんだけど
ある時は寒さに弱い ある時は寒いかともわからない
その時その時なんですね
だから自分ではその日に合わせるんです
なんか今日はすごい寒いなと思ったら
人がどう思おうか 私は関係なく
もう何枚か着る 全然もう寒くないと感じる場合は
人が何言おうがまあ薄着でいると
どういうになっても薄着でいる方が気持ちよくて気楽なんです
肩は凍りませんしね どうしても凍りませんですけど
まああまり服を着すぎると
まあこういう肩ほど服を着る必要ないと思います
最近もっと頭がよくなってね
前はもう正直に喋ってました
だからかなりみんなに怒られたんですよ
まあ寒いでしょうと親切に言ってくれて
まあ別にって言われると
もうすごい嫌な顔をするんですね
それでまあ最近もうちょっと大人にしよとなりまして
私は全然寒くなんともないんだけど
今日はちょっと寒いです
そうなんですねとすごい賛成で
言ったらえらい喜んじゃうんです
じゃあこの線でいこうと
人ということは そのままで返してあげれば楽やと
最近になってわかったんです ３
日前 ちょっと店 ある店に寄ったんだけど
それで品物を買おうと
それ注文する ちょっと時間なくて
まあまた他の日に来ますよと
で １分で帰りましたけど
その１分で店の人はものすごく喜ばせちゃったんで
もうこの人はもう気持ちよくて
もうゲラゲラ笑って楽しくて
いつでも来てくださいと
別に何もやったわけじゃないんで
その人言ってるけど 全部もうもっと面白くしてお話しして返してあげたんです
だからすごい楽なんですね
ああ そうですか なるほどとか何とか言ってあげれば
そのように まあそれすいません
脱線して申し訳ないんですけど
我々の場合は情報が入ったら
それにいろんな情報をつなげて考えているんです
何か情報が入ったら 例えば寒い
冷たい空気 体に触れる
まあ触れたらそれで寒く感じる
そこまではもう受動的で
それは管理できません
それから自分で思考を持っていくんですよ
ですから ３人が外に出るとしましょう ３
人が外に出たら 冷たい空気は体に触れる
そこまで同じでしょうに ３
人と そこでどうせ同じね
温度を持っている 体温は同じ生物でしょうし
だから空気の温度も決まっているし
そうすると反応っていうのは一応決まってます
それで寒いと感じる でもそこから大変なんですね
その３人が何を考えているんですかと
それについて それが決して一定はしないね ３
種類なんですね ですから
こうやってちょっと数学的に考えてみましょう
だから この人がまあ寒さに触れたとします
それで結果として思考が生まれたとしますね
であるならば 誰が寒さに触れても同じ結果になるはずなんですよ
でもそうじゃないんでしょう
例えば円持っているならば
誰でも自動販売機でコーヒー缶一つぐらいは買えます
そこで我々のは論理作れますよ
円があってあるならば
この自動販売機で誰でもジュース買えますよと
そこでこのを入れてボタンを押した人は
子供であろうか 大人であろうが
女であろうが男であろうが関係なく
ポソンと結果が出てきます
結果は同じなんです 因果法則っていうのはそういうものなんです
それで思考の場合はどうですかね
冷たい空気に触れたら誰でもこんな思考しますよとありますかね
だから何考えているかわからないんですよ
だから私は原田さんという私は考えることはもう随分親切に教えてくれると
先生だったらこう考えるでしょうと
本当は私はこの私の説法なんか聞いたってもね
私の思考パターンがわかるわけじゃないと思いますけど
それはわからないと思います
で 大体まあ思考のいろいろ方法がありましてね
いろいろ方法あります
まだまだそこら辺知りません
だから今日もなかなか時間なくて教えられないと思いますけどね
物事を考える方法っていうのはいろいろありますよ
その中で私が使っている方法っていうのは
全く相手に感知できない方法があります
それを使って人は感知するところでは
どこら辺まで感知してほしいかというところらへん
自分が管理して出すんです
そこら辺は読まれたっても
それが本当の本物じゃないんです
それは置いておいて それで思考っていうのはそうやって非科学的なことになるんですよ
思考自体が円入れてボタンを押せば缶ジュースを１本出てくるというように
もう はっきりした因果関係がないんですね
だからこれは自動販売機に例えると
この自動販売機に円を押せば何かが出るということになるんです
何かが出る それが何かはわからない
缶ジュースぐらい出てればまあありがたいことなんですけど
もし何かね 毒蛇でも出たらと
手を出しちゃうと死んじゃうでしょうに
例えば あの ナイトリックアシッド
サルフリックアシッド
日本語で何て言いますか？ナイトリックアシッド
サルフリックアシッドとかあるで
なんとか酸とかね 核酸
核酸 ナイトリック酸は核酸
H２SO４とかね 硫酸
もし硫酸でも出てきたら １２０
ボルトで どうしますかと
筋肉まで溶けてしまっちゃうと
だから何かが出るという方程式なんですね
人間の場合は だからこの寒さに触れると
結果として何かが思考出る
それは何かわからない
それ そういうわけだから
仏教はあまりこの考えることっていうのは素晴らしくてありがたいものやっていうふうに思ってないんです
自動販売機で何かボタンを押すと何かが出るんだけど
これ困るでしょうね 硫酸なんか出たらもうこれ困るでしょうね
今 缶ではなくてプラスチックもあるでしょう
それに硫酸入れちゃって
自分がジュースと思って飲んだところでも
これも 困るでしょうね
蛇でも出てきたら困るでしょうね
タランチュラという蜘蛛でも出てきたら
だからその木の思考にあります
ですから 人が 3人いれば 3種類の思考で
1 万人  1億人いれば 1億人の思考で
それで誰の思考は我々当てにするんですか？誰の思考も当てにならない
なぜならば それが論理的な思考
科学的な思考ではありませんだから
勝手で何か考えちゃう
それが思考の基本的な働きなんです
故に仏教はまあただ何か考えただけやと
でも何かが出ることはもう確かですよ
何か考えちゃう ですから
我々のデータっていうのは
眼耳鼻舌身意という六感がありまして
それには色やら形やら目で
音は耳で 鼻で 香りとか
舌で味とか 体で寒い硬いとか
その２つと それで意識でいろんな概念やらいろんなものというふうに
まあ色即身即法というふうに６つですよ
データが その６つのデータについて
世の中にある思考の量を見ると
一人一人が自分の思考を書いたり発表したりして
すごい量でしょうね 単純に
六つのデータなんです
目に入るデータには あの仏教専門用語で色というんですけど
パーリ語でルーパというんですが
ルーパというのは色とか形なんですよ
耳に入るデータにサッダと言うんですね
サッダ それは音ということ
音波のことですよ 鼻に入るデータにはガンダと言うんです
それはまあ鼻に入る香りのこと
香りだと気持ちいいものだけじゃなくて
臭いということも香りに入るんです
こうですね 舌に入るものにはワサという味ということなんです
で 体に入るものはもう簡単にして
仏教ではポッタッバというんです
ポッタッバっていうのは触れるということで
日本語で触とか言いますけど
体にはこの物質が触れますよ
それは触れるということで
ポッタッバとパーリ語で言うんです
触れる場合はもう硬いか寒いか
その二つしかわからないんです
硬くなきゃわかりません
例えば空気触れるでしょ
空気のあの硬い なんか砂のようなものが触れると空気だとわかるんですよ
だからたくさん触れると人が倒れますから
それで温度はわかります
だからそれ硬いか熱が歩かないか
それ二つしか体から情報が入りません
それで意識で考えるものには
仏教ではダンマというんですね
だから真理にもダンマというんですけど
その場合は真理という意味ではないんで
ただまあいろいろものということで
現象ということで ダンマという言葉はわざと使うんですよ
なぜならば 現象 元のものという元素
そのどちらにも使う そういう分大きい言葉なんです
どんな訳しなくてもいいんじゃないかというぐらいの言葉なんですね
プリンシプルにも使うし
法則にも使うし 真理にも使うし
ただ物事という場合も使うし
だからもうそれややこしい言葉で
わざとそういうややこしい言葉を使うんです
なぜならば 脳で何考えるかという場合は
それで一番いとも簡単に説明できますから
そういうのは言葉選びは厳重に厳密に計算して言葉選んでるんです
仏教のお釈迦様の話の場合は
まあだからダンマっていうのは日本語で言えば法なんですけど
まあ現象 物事というふうにしておいてください
意味は そこで色 形 音 香り
味などなど この六つのデータだけ
体に入れてよく考えること
世の中で 困難かどれぐらいありますかね
全部考えたもんですよ
だから機能として見て
これはまあある面で言えば
まあ仏教というのは科学ですから
思考の科学を語ってます
思考って何なのか ザ・サイエンスオブシンキングという
サイエンティフィックウェイオブシンキングではなくて
サイエンスオブシンキング
思考って何なのかと 思考学ですね
そこでその六つのデータが体に流れ込んで
体に触れて 我々は好き勝手で考える
だからデータが触れたら何かを考えるという方程式になるんです
これは言えません 人が納豆を食べ食べたらこういうことを考える
オレンジジュース飲んだらこのことを考えるということは成り立ちません
椅子に座ったらこういうことを考える
座布団に座ったらこういうことを考えるということは絶対言えない
ありえない だから どんな人を座布団に座っても
体に受ける感覚はほぼ同じ
が 何考えるかということはそちらへんはわかりません
ですから データが入ったら何かを考えるという方程式なんです
そのわけで 思考は頼りにならないんです
世界中全ての人々は絶対的に頼りにしているのは思考なんです
我々の文化やらありとあらゆるすべてのものは
我々は思考に頼っているんです
それでお釈迦様が言うのは
それが頼りになりませんと
頼りにならないのはそれですと
思考ですと だって非科学的でしょう
方程式さえ成り立たないでしょう
だから早く大阪に行きたいと思うならば
新幹線は頼りになります
物理学の公式 定式に基づいて作っているんだから
ちゃんと３時間以内で運ばせてくれるんです
でも 人間の思考はもう頼りにならない
だから 例えばある人に何かお願いに行きます
頼みに行きます 行ったらもうこの人にすごい怒られて断られたりする
そうすると私たちやることが選手交代するんです
他の人を出すんです 君が行って頼んでくださいと
そうするとうまくOK出ましたと
あれ 何やと 何かやりませんと
と決めたならば もうある人が行って頼んだら
ダメです 絶対やりませんと言って他の人を頼むと
なんでそんなもんでしょ
思考っていうの だからすごい危険ですよ
例えば私が誰かにね あんた
その隣の人に殴ってくださいと
隣の人を殴ってくださいと言う
そうすると冗談じゃないんですと
何言うんですかと言うかもしれませんね
殴れませんね それで安全ですかね
もし選手交代してみたら
殴る可能性あります 私もよくあることで
私が言うことはもうまず反対って認めないということになりますし
私も ちょっと大げさに言う時はね
もう反対の気持ち生まれるようにからくりをして言っちゃうし
まあこれはこちらの遊びで
それで街別の誰かに同じことを言われると
素晴らしいですね あなた言った通りに賛成するんですね
だから私は笑っちゃうんです
頭のいい人が言った時は認めないで
何も知らない人が言われると
あんた認めるんではないかと
その出来事はお釈迦様の時代でもありまして
ある人がね 大変子供が死んで悲しくて悲しくて
お釈迦様に会ったらね
お釈迦様がもうそんなもんはもうあんた子供が好きでしたからね
好きなものからろくな結果が出てくる
憂い悲しみしか出てきません
そしたらもう腹が立って
何言うんですかと すごいかわいい子でしたではないかということで
帰ると もうもうもう愛知の連中が影ごとやってるんです
仕事もしないで その人ことはあんたどこ行ったの？お釈迦様に何言ったんだ？お釈迦様何言ったんですか？と言ったら
お釈迦様がね こういう好きなものっていうのはね
憂い悲しみの元やと言うんだと
あのアホが何言うんですかと
この愛知の人々 好きなものがあれば
それこそ幸せでしょう
人間にと 言われたらすごく恥を感じたんですね
この人が 自分が まあ本当は仏教の信者さんで
お釈迦様とも仲がいい人でね
なんで私の思考がこのだらしない
もう社会から追い出されている人々の思考とハメますけど
あの偉大なるお釈迦様の思考とハメないねと
ということで すごい反省してしまったと
まあ思考っていうのはそういうもんでね
まあ時々よくよくあることで
ですから この次に覚えてほしいことは
思考自体が頼りにならない
我々は思考で動いて行動しているんですよ
えらい危険なんです その思考っていうのは非科学的ないい加減なものでしょう
なのに私が何しゃべるか
何をするかということは
思考が決める 智慧が決めるんじゃないんです
この思考が決める 冗談じゃないでしょうに
自分の人格 性格 何を決めるんですか？何がそれを管理して決めてるんですかね
自分の思考がそれを管理して決めているんですよ
とんでもない話じゃないんですか？もし私の話に乗っていたならばわかりますよ
その理屈は 自分の思考で戯れていたらどうにもなりませんね
私はすごい頑張って この思考の流れをね
説明しようと延々と同じことを繰り返しています
もうたくさんデータがありますから
そんなに時間もないんですけどね
繰り返す時間はないんですけど
ですから 思考っていうのはデータが入ったら何かを考えるという方程式でしょ
データが入る 何かを考える YOU
シンクサムシング or アニシング
データをインプットする
アウトプットは何でもいいやと
というなんかえらい変でしょうに
でもインプットは管理しているんです
誰も耳で蜂蜜を味わってみようとはしない
目で あのワサビ食べてみようとはしないんですね
だから我々はインプットの情報はきちんと管理しているんです
アウトプットはどうでもいいと
原子あれやりますね 発電所
あれ 原子原子力の発電所
インプットもアウトプットも厳密に管理しているでしょうに
そこでインプットだけ
いわゆるウランを原子炉で燃えるようにインプットだけ丁寧に管理して
アウトプットはどうでもいいとしたらどうなるんですかね
そこですごいことになるでしょうね
だから原子力発電所に行ったら
一番管理厳しいのはアウトプットのところなんです
ウランの延べ棒なんかはそんなに危険ということじゃない
もう何かに差し込んで置いておけば大丈夫ですよ
原子炉の核反応っていうのは簡単にストップできますよ
それはそれなりに何か板がありまして
それを打ちたらすぐ止まるんです
でもすごい厳密に管理しているのは
そのインプットの方よりもアウトプットの方なんです
それは危険です だからアウトプットでしょ
我々に必要なのは どんなものでも
料理のやり方よりは 最終的にこれが料理ですよと出てくるアウトプットが大事なんです
食卓に来るものが食べてるんだからね
料理の過程は抜群にうまくあっても
出来上がった魚はものすごく黒く焼けて
もう炭だったら もうこれ食べられないでしょうに
もっと丁寧に丹念に時間かけて魚を焼きましょうと言って
もう 30 分かけて あるいは 1時間かけて
もうあれ なんていいますか
トースターなんとか それで魚を焼いたとします
それで魚が焼かれて もう炭になったところで丁寧に食卓に持ってくる
食べられませんでしょう
だから人が丁寧にやったかないか
それはどうでもいいんですよ
だから結局は世の中で一番大事なのはアウトプット
私の発音はおかしいんですけど
まあ英語ではアウトプットなんですよ
これ日本語になっちゃうと何でしたかね
まあ一応出力って言ったらちょっとおかしいんだからね
それはアウトプットにならないか
え？まあ結果でしょうね
これ結果は管理不可能だというと
生きていられますかね
そこで世の中で結果が管理不可能なのはたった一つ
それは思考です 他の体のことは管理
結果わかります 人を 10 キロ歩かされると
結果もう歩かせる前にわかってるでしょ
体のこともわかってるんです
そんな難しいことじゃないんです
だから この体の場合でも
体のことはもう管理できる
結果わかってます やる前にも
例えば今日出発してアフリカに行くと
アフリカはもう一年中暑いでしょうに
そこで成田に行くまで
もうなんとか服を持っていくんだけど
向こう行ったらもう半袖のなんとかとかね
半ズボンとかね それ 2 3枚あれば十分です
こちらでそんなものを着ちゃうと
もうだからアフリカに行く前に
もう向こうの状況はわかります
それは体のことだから
だから思考の場合は結果推測不可能
だからお釈迦様の立場から言えば
結果推測不可能 どんな結果できるかもわからない
全くもあてにならない思考に基づいて
よくも人間生きていることで
それを応援するべきかと
だからなんですよ 人間のことは一番
ものすごいもう管理不可能な
どうにもならんもう生き物なんです
ある日 このある人がお釈迦様の能力に驚いちゃって
若者ですけどね この人は馬の調教師なんです
えらいプロ ものすごいもう天才的な能力がある
馬については そこでお釈迦様とちょっと付き合いに行って
まあもう昔の人々も そっちをお釈迦様といろいろ話したりとか
いろいろしていたんだからね
その彼は別にそっち行く人だからね
そこにいてお釈迦さん説法することを聞いたりしていて
なんとなく驚いてしまっちゃったんですね
だって 来る来る人がいろんな変な質問したりするんだけど
お釈迦様はもううまく答えて
一人一人がもう納得させて
もう帰るときはある人は悟るわ
ある人はちゃんと仏教徒になって帰るわ
ある人はもうすぐそばで出家まで決めるわ
今までの一生の生き方はすぐ瞬時に変えちゃうと
だから人間調教の場合は
これはなんたることかと驚いちゃって
お釈迦様に言うんですね
びっくりしましたよと
だって お釈迦様 私はね
馬のことだったら調教できますよと
馬っていうのは何考えてるかすぐわかるんだよと
すぐわかるんだと 何欲しがっているか
何考えてるか 人間っていうのはまるっきりわからないと
どうやっても人間何考えてるかわからないんだと
人間喋ってることから
この人このようなことを考えていると思うととんでもない話なんです
人間の行動を見て あ この人はこういうことを考えているんだと
とんでもない話なんです
人間の行動を見たっても
考え方を見ても いろんなやり方を見ても
考えてること自体はわかりません
一つ考えて無知なものを言う
だからわがままでも 例えば国の税金を自分で好き勝手に使いたければ
まあ国民のために命尽くして頑張りますと言うんです
それで ああ そうですね
この人と言ったら 一旦はい
わかりました 任せますと言ったところで
やっていることは別なんですけど
命尽くすんじゃなくて
税金尽くしてくれるんです
ということになるんですよ
ですから お釈迦様にはびっくりやと
お釈迦様もそうだよと
まあ若者だからね そうだよ
人間っていうのはね 全く当てにならないんだと
そこで如来は法則を知っているんだから
まあ管理しているだけですよと
この能力はまあお釈迦様にしかないんです
だからこのイティピソバグアという経で
このプリサダンマサーリプッタという言葉があります
人間なんて言ったっけ？上悟上悟成仏という
ちょっと難しい感じですけどね
いわゆる私の知っている変な日本語で言えば
人間の管理上司ですと
この上ない人間の管理者なんです
だからまるっきり非科学的なことを扱っているんだから
宅急便に 今 宅急便は随分繁盛している時期でしょうしね
だから宅急便に頼む 頼む
頼んじゃうと こちらが何か品物を宅急便に委託すると
そこはその こちらはまあ １キロぐらいの品物ですよと
これは野菜ですよと言って
その人に渡したところで
その人取りで この 1 キロは突然 10キロになったりすると
これ当てにならないでしょうに
それで 10キロ野菜なんですけど
車に入れたところで野菜は魚になったとかね
それでほんの 30分になってくると
もう魚は別に石になったとかね
またもうもう 10キロ行ったところで石がまたと
そうすると 受け取る側のところに何が何へ行くんですかね
何かに変化するという仮定にしておけば
思考というのはそんなもんなんですよ
それを管理するということは大変なことなんです
ブッダに以外 誰にもできません
例えば 思考ってどういう機能かと
西洋でいまだに勉強してないんです
ですからね まあとにかく一番目のポイントは思考っていうのは
まあだから仏教はあまり素晴らしいものやと思ってないんです
それからもう一つ 私たちの受け取り方
情報の それもそれほど正しくないんですね
例えば音が耳に入るとしたっても
耳の状態によって受け取る情報が変わっちゃうし
それから音が出た場所と自分のいる距離によっても音の質が変わるし
それで他の雑音も入り込みます
場合は どれぐらい自分がこれは越すことできるかというね
それによって 例えば私がこちらで喋っても
下に行くとそこら辺からいろんな雑音
雑音が入るでしょうに
だからそこら辺 窓からそちらの雑音が入っちゃうでしょうね
だからこちらで私が出す音じゃないんですよ
そちらの耳に入るのは
だから必ず私の声を聞きたければ
そのその人は自分で耳でこの雑音を越して
もう脳に必要な音だけ入れるという
その能力もしなくちゃいけないでしょうに
だから我々のデータの受け取り方も様々です
平等ではありません でもそこら辺は非科学的というわけじゃないんです
そこら辺は理解できます
管理もできます 例えば耳でちょっと音を聞いている方法がちょっと難しいなと言ったら
それ何か機械の器具なんか付けちゃえばね
管理できるし そこら辺
非科学的ではないんだけど
一定していないんです
今 私は私の目も信頼しません
まあ昔はかなり視力はありましたし
すごい明確に鋭く見えていたつもりでしたけど
目がどんどん衰えていくし
なんかコンピューターやりすぎて目の位置もずれているし
だから時々疲れてくると二つに見えちゃうんですね
で いろいろ病気なんですから
今自分では信頼していません
見えているものはいろいろいろんな事務所でもちょっとデザインなんかしてると私に聞くんだけど
私に聞いたっても 自分では信頼しないんだからね
だから私にはこれを 私にはこれ綺麗に見えるんだけどということで終わっちゃうんですね
ですから このデータの受け取り方は
まあそれは科学的な法則で送ります
送りますが 一定してないんですね
それで我々に入るデータもいい加減なことで
それで私たちはもうなんとか思う
心の中でこれはきれいな音だとかね
これはきれいな音じゃないとかね
それに基づいて考える
だから結局はデータさえも正しくというか
まあそんなにね 信頼できない
それからまあ自分で考える
考える 考える それで私は瞑想を指導するときはよく使う例で
実践的な場合はね バラの花一つ一本見るといかがでしょうかと
綺麗でしょう まあ綺麗ですよと
私は違いますよと それはあなたが綺麗やと思ってるだけですよと
故にバラの花が綺麗という思考は
永遠不滅の普遍的な真理ではありませんと
それはあなた勝手な思考ですよ
あなたの主観だよと そこでどんな人間に聞いたっても
まあバラの花 これは綺麗よと言うかもしれませんだけど
当てになりませんと もしかすると
ただ言葉に乗っって乗ってるだけ
花は綺麗は当たり前 決まってるんだと
みんなそう言ってるんだから
まあ俺も言ってやるぞと
ということになるかもしれませんし
それで個人個人でバラに対するというのはアプローチが違うでしょうに
だから私がバラの花が見て
バラの花綺麗 綺麗に決まってる言って人に言い伝えたり押し付けたりすると
そこら辺は人間関係崩れてしまう
そこでうまくいかなくなるんです
例えば 私は人に仕事を頼む
美しく花で飾ってほしいということで
私は大量のバラの花を買ってきて飾ってくださいと
自分の頭にはイメージがあるんですけど
それでその頼んだ人がバラの花買ってきて飾っちゃったのが
えらい自分にとっては機嫌が悪いとことになるんです
だから仕事もうまくいかなかったと
希望通りにいかなかったと
それでケンカになっちゃうんです
それは自分の主観正しいと思ったところから
そういう期待外れの結果になるんです
難しいんですよ そこですごく柔らかくて
なんかおかゆみたいなご飯食べたい人が
ああ こういうすごく柔らかくてね
もうもうそういうご飯なんといしいかといて
それでもう考えて 本人が頭で私はご飯大好きですよと
いで 誰かにじゃあまあ聞かれたら
何食べてもご飯だったらありがたいなと
はい わかりましたと 人にもご飯作ろうとすると
もしその人はタイ人でタイ米好きで
あの人ご飯好きだから
まあタイ米でご飯炊いてあげましょうと思って
タイ米でご飯炊いてると
まあ味が違うんですね
硬いといえば硬くはないんだけど
日本人が硬いと思っているんです
日本人の考えで 日本人がタイ米は美味しくないと思っているんです
私はそう思っているわけでもないし
タイ人もそう思ってはないんですけどね
そこで日本人が美味しいご飯
もうすごい柔らかいご飯を食べたくてタイ人に頼む
その人は一生懸命だったら一番美味しいご飯作ってあげるぞと
その人っているのはタイ米だからね
日本では何光あれやれと全部同じでしょ
名前だけ違って それで誰か誰かにこの試食してもらったんですよ
一番美味しいものを言ってください
ご飯の種類を言わないで言ったら
標準米食べてね これが一番美味しいやと
でも買う時はなんとかなんとか買うんですよ
だからくだらんでいい加減でね
それに気づかないところはすごい面白いんです
私はすごい美味しいなんとか米しか食べませんと威張っているところはね
それで種類を言わないで目隠しさせて食べさせ
食べさせてみると また違う結果が出てくる
まあそういうことだから
それで人がその人のご飯作ってくださいと言ったところで
あら 期待外れでこんなものは食えないんだと
なんであんたに頼んだ仕事をしっかりできないんですかと
ということで 管理問題とかね
それはまあ 会社なんかに例えてみてください
このタイ米の例を なんでうまくいかなかったかというと
やっぱりそれぞれ主観の問題なんです
だから世の中うまくいかない
会社がうまくいかない
夫婦がうまくいかないとか
いろいろ言ってるでしょうに
これがこの思考の主観の問題ですよ
自分の頭でいい奥さんって何なのかとイメージ作って勝手にいたっても
それを相手に期待する
うまくいかないんです
それで女性の方も もう理想な旦那ってそんなもんやと自分勝手に何かあって
それは実際の生の旦那に当てはめてみると合ってないと
それでうまくいかなくなっちゃうんです
それでもう私には聞かないんだけど
すごい哲学者やら宗教家に聞くんですね
夫婦円満の秘訣は何なのかと
そうすると分かってないんだから
すごく丁寧に教えてくれる
もっとひどくなる方法
私に聞かないのは 私は答え決まってますから
離れなさいと うまくいかないんだと
だからこの人に聞いたっても
頭が悪いんだから当てにならないってことで
もうそういういろいろ秘訣を教える人には聞いてくるんです
それで私がバラの花は綺麗だと思ったっても
全ての人類にバラの花が綺麗っていうことではない
そのその人が 例えばよく出す例っていうのは
女の人に振られた人がバラの花束を持って行って
まあ付き合いましょうといったところでいい加減にしなさいと言われたら
すごいショックを受けちゃった
受けたならばね まあ女性はそれはあまり気にしないかな
わかりませんだけど まあ男の場合
もしかするとね 神経質の男だったらえらい気にする
で その人にとってはバラの花を見ると
あの思い出が出てくるでしょうね
だから同じ綺麗という感覚は生まれてこない
それから バラの花が綺麗であるならば
人間のみならず 鳥にも犬にも猫にも
全てどんな獣にも綺麗でなければいけません
でも犬は全然綺麗やと思わないし
また色も見えないしね
鳥には色見えるんだけど
別に虫がいればいいんじゃないかなとか
それで終わっちゃうんですね
虫もないこのバラは何なのかと
となるでしょうし ですから
猫がゴキブリを見たらすごく喜んじゃって
なんと面白いかと思っちゃうし
我々はゴキブリ見たら
ああ なんて気持ち悪いかと思っちゃうし
だから我々のこの思考のデータ全てが主観的で
それぞれ別々 もうあまり普遍的な真理ではありません
だから実際に物体としてのバラの花なんですけど
それが猫を見て面白くないやと思っちゃうし
人間見てなんと綺麗やと思っちゃうし
だから思考するために私たちはいただく
受け取るデータ自体も
我々は改良して自分の主観で受け取っています
そこで結果としては 我々は互いに逆らう
互いに喧嘩する 仲良く生きることはまるっきりできません
世の中で全くも成り立たないのは調和と平和なんです
日本文化は一生懸命頑張っているでしょ
和を守ろうと この世の中でできないのはそれなんです
和を保つこと なりたけません
でも人間っていうのは
やっぱりこのお互いに和を保たないことは苦しいやと
喧嘩することは苦しいやと
仕事を失敗することは嫌やと
夫婦は喧嘩して別れることは
それは嫌やと思っているんですけど
方法はわからない だったら
この思考の方程式を勉強して思考に頼らないこと
で いくらかあの和を保つ
例えば夫婦喧嘩する場合は
奥さんは自分考えていることはこう考えたとしても全然気にしないと
自分が考えていることは
相手も自分が考えることを全然気にしないということになったら
それだけのことでしょうに
それから何で喧嘩 何で喧嘩するんですか？喧嘩にならなくなっちゃうんです
だから喧嘩になるのは
自分考えていることが正しいんだと
事実だと それだけですよ
世の中のあらゆる戦いのいさかいの原因が
私が思うものが正しいよと
それさえなければ 思うのは勝手でいいんですけど
正しいと思うなよと だって非科学的だから
何かが結果出る それだけだけのことだから
旦那さんのポケットに何かマッチやら何かの飲み屋さんの何か見つかると
そちらの口紅もついているということで
それで奥さんが何かを考える
こうも何考えるかわからないんですよ
例えば それなりに世間知ってる奥さんだったら
まあそれはまあそんなもんで
仕事に出ているんだから
どうせ付き合いしなくちゃいけないし
そういうところはまあ女ね
女が酒注ぐためにいるということはもう決まってる事実でしょうに
この世の中で 全然それにこの退職しているおじいさんなんか頼む仕事を頼んでないんだから
だから人間っていうのは
そのその年によって性格が違うでしょうしね
それでできた奥さんだったら
まあ別にそんなもんかってことでね
終わっちゃうし 世間知らず
家のこの壁の 4つだけの世界で
私はすべて知ってるんだと威張ってる奥さんだったら
あんた浮気したんではないかとかね
なんだこれは？というふうに思ったりするでしょう
それはどちらでも別にどうったことないんですよ
思考だからね 本当に浮気してるんだったら
きちんと証拠を握ったところ
それは浮気なんです より 100%の証拠さえあれば
それはもう浮気であって思考ではありません
事実ですから だから人間というのは正しい事実については喧嘩しません
思考の場合は喧嘩する
だから私はよく言うのは
地球は丸いということには誰も人殺しはしません
でも アッラーは偉大なりという思考によっては
多数の人々は死んでしまうんです
不幸になるんです あれは思考であって
科学的な事実ではありません
世の中でいろいろ本があるでしょうに
本はどのように出来上がるということをみんなはわかっているでしょうに
誰かの思考が文字にするだけのことです
それで でも コーランのみ神の言葉だと
そういう思考が入っちゃうと
それはすごい危険な結果になってくるんですね
でも そういうふうな方々も
地球は丸いということに対しては喧嘩しません
パンは人間に食べられる食物
植物ですよと言っても
殺してやるとは言いませんね
事実ですから だから事実の世界ではみんな平和なんです
思考の世界では平和ではありません
それで思考が正しいというところではなくて
もう全くももう当てにならないものであると
誰の思考でも だから仏教でもすごい気をつけなさいとね
仏教こそ正しいとかは
まあ言うなよと それは仏教は正しいんだからそう言ってるんです
ちゃんと思考って取ってるんだから
ちゃんと信条を取ってるんだから
そう言う必要もないんだと
逆にもし間違っているならば言ってごらんなさいと
もし私が言うこと間違っているならば言ってごらんなさいと
というふうにチャレンジかけるんですね
思考で まあ仏教こそ正しい教えですよ
これこそやというと 私さえもすごく気持ち悪くなるんです
時々聞く時もあったんですよ
さすがもうやっぱりブッダの浄土真宗仏教とこそ
これ日本人に言われるとものすごく気持ち悪くなってくる
分かってはないくせに何言ってるんでしょうか
と この人は危険人物やと
この人に洗脳されてしてもらっちゃうと困ります
これ正直な話 えらい気持ち悪くなるんです
そんな感情的で これこそやと言っては
1週間で他のものはこれこそやと言うんだからね
智慧のある人はすぐ見ただけで
これこそって決めません
よく調べる 調べて経験済みのところは
まあここら辺は経験済みで
まあこういうこういう状況だよということを問わちゃうんです
だから仏教の場合はやっぱりこれこそこれこそということは言うなかれと
事実を語ってあげて 何か違うと思うならば
相手がそれはチャレンジしてみればいいのです
それでタイトルなんで
思考する人はね 考える人は苦しみと
そのタイトルになったのは簡単なことで
こんなもんだですよ 人間というのはえらい
あれ苦しい これ苦しい
いろいろあるでしょうに
こんなもの全部考え方なんですよ
まあほとんど考えているんだからなんですよ
ほとんど何考えるか 過去の出来事
終わった出来事 全くもう終わった出来事をずっと考えている
それで不幸に苦しむことになっちゃうんです
それからもう起きようとも知らない将来について考える
そうすると どんどんどんどん不安がもうどんどん強化していく
不安で不安でたまらなくなる
自分でやっていることでしょうに
これさえやめれば気楽でしょうに
だから考えることっていうのは
この無限に苦しみを作るんです
無限に苦しむんです 例えば
まあまあよくそれで私は言いますけどね
まあ例えば離婚したと
もうそれですごく悩んで悩んで悩んで苦しんでいると
もう離婚したならもう終わっちゃったんだからね
今どうするべきかということでしょうね
仕事は 特に精神的に 病気な人々の場合はみんな過去の出来事でしょ
子供の頃こうなってああなったとか
なんとか過去のことをいちいちいちいちいちいちそればっかり考えている
それで不幸になって苦しくなる
今も皆様は考えてください
もしかしたら皆様の家が今火事になっているかもしれませんよ
泥棒が入っているかも
今日もテレビでニュースありましたけど
今はものすごいプロ的にものすごい
中国の犯罪グループがね
ピッキングはすごい上手だと
ピッキングの王様という帝王と言えるほどの能力ある人がいるのはすぐ教えてくれるんだと
他の中国人にもう家に入っているかもしれませんよ
それに情報がね ちゃんと入っているんだと
これ情報はどこから来るんですか？と
その人を中国人にインタビューされてやったんで
聞いたら それは日本人がちゃんと教えてくれるんだと
でお金はどこに？大体この社長はいつ出ているか
奥さんがいつ出ていくかとかね
それで大体大金取れるのは
みんな税金払わないで
お金をだまして あっちこっち隠しておくんだよ
家で だからそこら辺は会社の人々は知っていて
社長がお金あっち置いてありますよ
こちら置いてありますよと知っているんだよと
そこら辺は何のことなく教えてくれるんだと
それでその時間を見て
サッと部屋を開けてお金を取って帰るんだと
だから私は真面目な話で
皆様のこともそうやって情報が中国人に流れている可能性はあります
ですから もう家に帰ると
もうもう入ってますよ
だって今正月でしょうし
みんな忙しくてあちこち家にいないしね
そんなこと考えたらどうですかね
気持ちは ですから 余計なことを考えるといくらでも苦しめるということなんです
いくらでも苦しめます
それでいいんでしょうかと
それで能力ですかね そんなもんは
だから考えることはもうそれこそ危険なもので
徹底的に気をつけなくちゃいかんことで
でも自動的に思考が生まれるんだったら
まあそれをそのまんまで放っておくか
もう相手にしないか どちらかなんですね
でも自動的に生まれるわけじゃないので
それはすべて能動的なんです
だからストップできます
だから最初から私は能動的だと言ったんです
わざと考えているんです
わざわざと それで泣くんです
私は苦しい 大変だ 不幸だとかね
なんで私はこんなに不幸な人間に生まれたんでしょうかとかね
だから仏教で笑っちゃいます
その瞬時に解決できる問題だと
そんじに直りますよ 幸福になれますよ
まあそういうことで やっぱり考えると苦しみが生まれてきます
私には才能がないと考えてみてください
それで幸福になりますかと
私は何をやっても失敗するんだよと
そうやって考えてみてください
楽になりますかね 大体思考するっていうのは
そんな方向へ思考するんですよ
あまりポジティブ方向へは考えません
それで世界では じゃあポジティブ方向に考えますと
ポジティブ思考 ポジティブシンキングとかね
流行ってる言葉あるでしょ？どうったことないんですよ
あんなもん だから別に私には才能がない
私は何をやっても失敗する
その相反手に私には才能がある
私は何をやっても成功してみせるというふうに考えたらうまくいきますか？うまくいきませんよ
それでそんなアホなことを考えたって
事実は事実だから だからそれも人間の行動にすごいハンディになるんです
ポジティブシンキングも
で 人間の９５％はネガティブシンキングですよ
これで５％ぐらいはポジティブシンキングで
その分 世の中でその人々はうまくいってます
でもだからその人の人格は立派かというとそうじゃないんですよ
それをまたえらい不安定で成功したっても
ポジティブシンキングありすぎて
例えばラビンさんはすごいポジティブシンキングでしたでしょうに
神は自分についているんだと
自分が神様の期待通りに
命令通りに仕事をする
神に使われている人物やと
ものすごいポジティブでしょう
だから絶対的な能力ある神様でしょうに
その神様に救われてもらうということ
それほどありがたいことはないでしょうね
結果はどうですかね ポジティブシンキングだったらそんなもんになっちゃうんです
アメリカもいろいろひどい目に遭うのは
これ ポジティブシンキングの結果なんです
我々はすごいと 強いと
アメリカで作る気にしなもの機械も結構失敗しますけどね
この宇宙開発計画などなどではね
どれほど財産無駄にするかというと
あのレーダーでも あのレーダーでも感知できないというステルスとか何とかと飛行機がもう落っちゃったでしょうに
あのボスニアの戦争の場合も
普通の鉄砲で撃たれて
それでポジティブシンキングで
それは別ななんとか間違いやと言って
自分の結果は認めませんと
だから そんなえらいポジティブシンキングで世界には迷惑
アルカイダやらそういう人々のポジティブシンキングでもう迷惑もいいところで
ネガティブシンキングはみんなやってますから
バサバサと言う必要はない
まあそれぞれ不幸になってるんだから
ハハハハ だからポジティブシンキングかネガティブシンキングかではなくて
シンキングが気をつけろなさいと
シンキングという思考というそういうもの
まあそれでこのネガティブシンキングが出てくると
自分がこの切羽 切羽というか
いわゆる失望感に入ってもうまくいかなくなっちゃう
やっぱポジティブシンキングになってくると
えらい欲望が出てきて
やむくもにもう頑張って全て壊してしまうと
だから ちゃんと論理的に物事を知っている人は
きちんと自己管理して
自分を自制して こういう目的にこういう風に行くんだそうと
と生活はします いわゆる思考は管理できますということ
管理できなきゃいいんだから
悪いこと  うーん それでなんで考えるんですかね
次のポイント なぜ考えるんですかね
私の答えは全くわからないんだから
それで全くもわからないんだったら
考えてればわかりますかね
いわゆる全くも知らない
全くわからない だから考えてるんですよ
でも結局無駄でしょうね
知ってるんだったら考える必要なくなっちゃうんです
ですから これが言いたい言葉
思考する人は愚か者であると
思考イコール無知なんです
だからよく考える人はよくももう
すごい人です だからあんまり深くものことを考えないで
寒いでそうですねとか
これぐらいで終わるとかね
お腹が空いた そうですね
何か食べましょう はい
じゃあ何食べましょう
まあそこら辺はこういうこういうものしかない
じゃあこれ食べましょうと
そういうふうに生きている人がね
あるいは家にはこれとこれ
私はこれそういうこと食べません
私は格好悪いんだと 私はすごい贅沢な人だからね
贅沢に豪華なものしか食べませんよとかね
いて じゃあどこかにごちそうを食べに行こうかなと言った時に
11時でもうコンビニしか開けてないとかことになるでしょうに
そういう人と ああ まあこれしかないな
じゃあもう何て言いますか
ラーメンしか じゃあこれお湯をかけて食べましょうという人と
だからまあ人生っていうのはやっぱり単純
単純というのはおかしいかもしれません
淡々と情報データに基づいていくらか考えて
それよりそれ以上はいかない
強引に思考しない場合は気楽に生きていられます
それであれやこれやとあまりにも考える人はあまりにも知らなさすぎなんです
そこで私は こういうふうに質問を出します
今日は何日？はい 今日何日？ 20 22 でしょうし
まあそれにも考えちゃったんですけどね
で クリスマスの日は 25 日
もう最近ですけどね 東京は雪降ると思いますか？では
それでもいくらかデータあるでしょうに
天気予報の だから温度はどれぐらいになるかとかね
言って答え出せばどうでしょうかね
だからその場合は今日何日と言えばもう考える必要ないんですよ
そこで 25 日は天気はどうなりますかというと
一生懸命考えるんですよ
その考え なぜ考えてるんですかね
知らんからでしょ だから考えることっていうのはイコール知らないということなんです
データがないということなんです
考えてるんだから立派っていうわけじゃないんです
すごいこの単純なことなんです
まあだからそこら辺 あまりややこしく言わなくたっても
やっぱり頭の中でガチャガチャガチャガチャ考えてるんだったら
簡単に大馬鹿者だと自分のことを決めつけてもうやめた方がいいんですよ
もうそんなにまたもう時間かけたり
もう面倒くさいんです
時間は早く変わっていくんだから
私はものすごくイライラするんです
早く治ると面倒くさいやと
あんただけに一生かける暇がないんだと
まだ他の人の悩みも解決しなくちゃいかんだから
これ 二 三分で治るものでしょう
二 三分で治ることには 20年かかってかかるんだったら
これも面倒くさくなっちゃうんですね
だからなんで単純で悪いんですかね
今日はこれ 今日はそれほど天気が悪くない
昨日と比べるといいんじゃないかな
それでなんで止まらないんですかね
ちょっと疲れた じゃあ休もう
そんなもんでなんで止まらないんですかね
気楽でしょうに 会社にいたっても社長が怒っていかん
ああ 社長が怒ったんだから
じゃあ話し合いましょうと自分でやめればいいでしょう
だからすごい頭の中はものすごい明晰で単純で
１ たす １は 489.11 ではなくて
１ たす １は ２ですよと
それでストップすればいいんです
我々の思考は １ たす １は 487.1
またまたまたまた行くんですね
なんでそんなに？だって
もし誰かがもう一つ出せばどうなるんでしょうかと
そうやって推測したり考えたりする
だから思考を管理したい人にはもうすごい推測もできるし
どんな反映だとわかるし
何かについていちいちいちいち考えるよりも
これについては考えられることはこれしかないやとまとめられます
簡単に どんな問題にしたって
そういうのは具体的な例を出さないと例はわかりにくいんですけどね
まあ一応そういうこと
それでも次に言いたいことはこういうこと
とにかく考える癖がついてるんだったら
まあ頭が悪いと決めてください
私は別に免許証を出さなくても
自分で書いて 自分の自分で書く証明書だから 100%あってますしね
人の評価じゃないんだからね
時効評価自己評価で で
簡単でよろしいということでね
それでも我々にはどうも考えることをやめられないということもあります
変なことを暗いこと考えれば
考えれば考えるはいつでもそのパターンで
それがだから考えることは受動的なものではないかと思ったりもする場合あります
そこら辺のダルマの真理は何なのかと
それがこの考えることと
この感情がくっついているんですよ
だからなんですよ 例えばこれがバラの花ですと言ったら
そうです バラの花ですと言って
すごいクールに受け取ることはできません
なんて綺麗ということも入っちゃうんです
これが私が飼ってる猫ですと言ったら
あ なんて可愛いなとかね
思うかもしれません すごい可愛い物体ではないかとも心の中で思っているかもしれませんしね
言わなくたっても だからいいということは何も果たしてませんだからね
で とにかく見た瞬間で感情が生まれるんですよ
この感情っていうのはどうにもならんことなんですよ
そこで感情が思考を引き起こしちゃうんですね
だからこの思考に感情がついている
余計なもんです あれは
えーと 何かいい例えがないんですかね
常に必ずしもついています
これが本当は余計 だから我々は
例えばバラについて語りましょうと
みんなで一緒にバラの花束を持ってきて語っても
うまく話し合いできません
感情があるんだから それで花のプロがいるんだったら
またガチャガチャうるさいし
そこで田中流の人と加古江流の人が入れたらまた喧嘩になっちゃうし
それで植物学者がいたならば
またうるさいしね それで花について語らなくなっちゃうんですよ
平和で なぜかというと
それぞれ花 花について語りますと言ったら
それぞれ個人の感情がべったりとついているんですね
これが臭いんですよ これが細菌です
この感情は言葉についている感情が
だって私のことにも悪口言ったり批判したりするでしょう
すごく堂々と それが私の言葉ではなくて
言葉を聞いたところで皆様の心に感情が生まれるんですよ
私は感情抜きに喋っているんですけど
だから堂々と失礼な言葉を言うんです
自分では失礼と思っていないんで
別にそんな感情がないんだから
でもうまくはそんなことで人間とうまくいきません
人間が感情を持っているんだから
だから言葉を聞いたら
我々はすごく気が立ったりとかね
気持ち悪くなったりとか
舞い上がったりとかするんでしょう
あれが問題なんです 例えばそちら様はというと
私がね お前はというと
とにかく言うという意味でしょ
結局は 私の前にいる人っていうのは
どうですか あの言葉 二つの感情は
だからあなたというね
私の前にいる物体という意味だけのことなんですけど
それに使う言葉によって喧嘩になるか
もうもうなんていうのは
関係が悪くなるか まあ大変ですよ
そこで私は目上の人なんですけど
お前はと言ったならば
その人はすごい もう態度傷ついた感情を作っちゃうんですよ
その人にこの態度傷ついたという怒り
その感情が受動的だからずっと流れるんですよ
このなんとか下水道の汚水流れているような感じで
それでそれにべったり言葉を投げるんですよ
我々思考というのはそんなもん
だから止まらなくなっちゃうんです
だから余計なことを妄想ばっかりしてどうにもならんというふうな人々が
問題はこの思考はストップできないわけじゃなくて
この感情の流れはなかなか自己管理できなくなっていることなんです
感情の流れは大体受動的になっているんです
そこで仏教はこの怒り
憎しみ 欲 そういう煩悩
感情 それの悪口をね それ壊しましょうと
それしか人類 人類に幸福な究極的な平和な道がありませんと
思考よりも感情に餌たくするんです
思考というのは言葉の並べ替えだから
これはどうったことはないです
ですから我々は何か考えて考えているんだけど
結局は欲あってあってもうこれでガチャガチャガチャガチャガチャガチャ考えて
あるいは怒り それでガチャガチャガチャガチャあるいは嫉妬
なんとかなんですよ それで止まれなくなっちゃうんですね
それで自己管理する方法っていうのは
自分で言葉に感情と言葉と分けてみる
ある切ってもらう 例えば人の話を「お前は」と自分に言う
誰かが 言われた瞬間でカッとなってくるかもしれませんよ
すぐ切るんです 「お前は」という言葉だけです
そこで意味は このあの人の前にいる私のことですよ
というふうに 科学科学的な世界に持ってくる
それにも怒ったりすると
次に何を言うかわからなくなるんだと
たとえ自分の心の中でそうやって感情が流れが現れても
これはこの何とかこの布も何か機械で編んでいるような感じで言葉を編んでくるんだけど
いらん何かも一つ機械の問題で出てくる
それはハサミ入れてずっと切っちゃえばいいんです
そこで必要なものだけ取ってもらうと
いろんな工場で品物を作る場合は
品の中で両側やらしたらだけ
砂機械につなげている部分もあるでしょうね
そこで品のようなところ
それはプチンと落として品物だけ取っちゃうでしょうに
そんな感じで人と喋ると
人が何言ったってもいいんですよ
当然 そのその言葉に感情がついています
それは全部ハサミで切って
知恵のハサミで切って
言葉だけを受け取って
そこで考えると そういう分
楽に話すこともできるし
生きることもできるようになるんです
だから 言葉についている感情は切り離す
そこで自分が一人勝ちでゴチャゴチャゴチャゴチャ考えて
不幸になるだけじゃなくて
精神的にイカれるところまで行っちゃうと
これは思考ではなくて
単なるこの煩悩のゴチャゴチャゴチャゴチャの回転だと
理解してもらえば解決方法はあるんです
私は偉そうなことを考えているんじゃなくて
ただ感情だけ ゴチャゴチャ回転してるんだよと
だからそれから次に言葉には決まってる感情がついていますか
この言葉にこの感情 この言葉にこの感情というのはついていますかね
それもないんですよ 例えばお前という言葉は
必ずしも怒り 怪怒 傷ついたという感情ですかね
そうじゃないでしょうに
その場でその場で それそれなりの感情がついてくるんだから
だからまあ そちら辺にもあまり客観的な論理はないんです
それで思考っていうのは単なる感情の
回転ですよ 怒りは怒りを生む
嫉妬が嫉妬を生む そういう心の法則があるんです
道理を生みますよ だって
鶏は決して猫を産みませんでしょう
鶏だよ 卵を産んでまた鶏を作ることですからね
メス猫にいくら頼んだっても
犬を産んでくれないでしょうに
だから  怒りは怒りを生む
嫉妬は嫉妬を生む だったら
これはもう根絶するしか方法ないんです
怒りをうまく使用して
使用していい結果出そうって
これはありえないんです
ニワトリをうまく使用して
競馬に使いましょうと
やめた方がいいと私は思いますけどね
そんな努力は ニワトリはニワトリですから
ですから この感情っていうのは
お釈迦様は根絶することは推薦する
これですっごいもうそうそう接する素晴らしい幸福な世界が
すぐその目の前で現れてきます
で 一応そこら辺で話を終了いたします